today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
hitter today's episode is also brought
to you by the creator and it is a short
film and this is our small business add
the creator is a new short film out of
Brisbane Australia it's about a young
woman being tracked down by a mysterious
man in the dense Australian forest
however not all is what it seems it's
black mirror Meets Wolf Creek in the
Creator you can watch it right now for
free no subscription BS nothing to sign
up click the Vimeo link in the
description below and enjoy it if you're
on Facebook you can find it by searching
the Creator short film the link will be
on the page if you're on Instagram just
search the filmmaker Darcy Wellborn
at the real Darcy 93 and click the link
in his bio the Creator a new sci-fi
short film out of Brisbane Australia get
that creator today's episode is brought
to you by Ridge wallet Ridge wallet have
that special kind of wallet tree that go
in your pocket but in your front pocket
remember when people used to carry stuff
in their back pocket I barely do because
that is way long ago bucko that's the
past I'm talking about now I'm talking
about the future I'm talking about whoa
what's next black mirror it is the ridge
wallet the ridge wallet is that front
pocket carry you know when I have mine
on me right now
and I'll even hit my you hear that
that's that ridge wallet tree and this
thing will hold your cards it'll hold
your ID it is concise and it is easy to
front pocket and it takes care of things
and even lasers can't get through this
and it could stop a bullet though I
wouldn't try that you can go to Ridge
wallet comm slash Theo th EO and use
code Theo at checkout for 10% off that's
Ridge wallet comm slash Theo for 10% off
or use code Theo at checkout for 10% off
Ridge wallet dot-com today's episode is
a man who let me state as
apartment one time for a long time in an
extended period of time and he is he's
one of a kind he's a rare element he's
that 60-second element from you know the
I don't know breath but here's what
I'm saying is this man is very special
you know him and he's always on the go
you know him from his skeptic tank
podcast and his Netflix special double
negative
he's coming up in he'll be in Columbus
he'll be in Cleveland or Cincinnati and
he'll be in Tempe and Phoenix give it up
for my friend mr. Ari Shaffir so that's
the thing I don't does care but like
it's like making racist jokes again
Edwards because we're always like oh I
want but I don't want you to write me
off as a person yes right now dude it's
so funny you say you know words if I
have something that I feel like it could
be racist I checked with the in Edwards
yeah yeah and he'll be like no it is
it's funny - yeah he'll at least yeah
he'll at least like give it a real
thought yeah he's like uh yeah I just
feel like he's just he just is about
comedy first yeah exactly
or he'll be like racism bad but racist
jokes aren't that bad yeah
well dude here's what I'm saying I'll
say this man a little racism one way
it's exciting oh yeah you know what I'm
saying like if you want to grow in a
place where there's no none at all
yeah pretty boring yeah where the food's
gonna be bad and I said this one pockets
tested actually good food you have to
have a little bit of racism in the air
oh was that because I think you know
you're just it might be the last meal
every time you know you never know like
yeah and I don't mean any specific
direction of racism but you got to have
some strife in the air dude a little bit
of stress in the pot
it goes a long way in the gut I'm not
sure I see the connection how does it
make well think about cities that have
good food yeah LA riots right Baltimore
Baltimore New York for sure New York
yeah Austin you know I heard about about
about in Houston all the comics there
they say Austin not all account
yeah but they say Austin because
Austin a rebellion gets anything it's
already fixed so I got nothing to speak
on but Houston you're in your
audience you got a bunch of rednecks
sometimes ya gotta you're goin at
somebody maybe you have somebody to go
at Austin like yeah we agree so what's
the joy right well that's a thing
sometime it's like I think some places
you get to a place where it's just
things are comfortable and there's no
there's nothing left to do so you have
to go and that's when the huns come in
and murder everybody just march
through the streets I never was like oh
really what happens yeah everyone's so
nice and friendly and then you know some
warring group comes in know one another
fight back they can beat you all with
like a you know pretty much one of those
black Jack's that's our flood could
happen in LA
my name somebody coming run over
everybody cuz everybody just gets so
soft do you I mean I feel like I get
softer out here living out here remember
that there was a there was a song about
two graduates Baz Luhrmann remember that
when it was like song to the graduates
Baz Luhrmann yeah he did a bunch of the
Romeo and Juliet soundtrack but he goes
uh live in LA but leave before you get
soft hmm or live in the west coast
believe it and then live on the east
coast but leave before you get too hard
Wow yeah yeah I feel like that man I
feel like it's like you know you start
getting afraid of things that are okay
like regular milk like oh no yeah
exactly
almond only please yeah it's art yeah
you just start to get a little yeah but
to my like I understand all right get
some almond milk it's fine but when
someone's like oh we just put
half-and-half in there don't be like no
yeah no all right through reckon relax
over all eat the often Bella if you get
a non-gm you know if you get a GMO thing
without their who cares one
thing yeah
you need a chicken nugget once
in a while brother yeah people think if
they eat a Mac nugget that is against
gays out here you know dude I have four
or five McNuggets they're not even
thinking about a man
I'll go get some McNuggets and then go
to an anti-gay protests Oh
stop me oh yeah that's oh that's
interesting Roderigo it's not even what
I believe it's like cool dudes hanging
out having fun dude sometimes I wonder
if do you ever feel like a lot of gay
men gay men get seemed to me also to be
very judgmental a lot of times here and
maybe I'll just see that in Los Angeles
and maybe it's something that just I
feel but I feel like it's not I feel
like gay men don't really support man
that much really they support other gay
men it seems like but I don't know if
they support this show on like unlike
one of the gay bars in Santa Monica
Boulevard yeah I mean listen most gay
men are fine but the Queen's are the
worst audience like shot app you don't
know yeah isn't a half your setups like
wait what and you're like you didn't
even pay attention any of this yeah shut
the up
it is sometimes come in to raise hell
and they some of them act like the
crosswalk is a model area for modeling
you know like later your dances yeah
yeah well I'll see a guy he just he's
not doing anything but crossing the
street all night and you know just flat
you know bragging about how he's
Infiniti boots and John Elliott pants
see but the thing is dudes are so
shallow and then when you get only dudes
and movemove women away that's why the
gay dudes are all jacked and worked out
not the Bears you know but a lot of them
are way more jacked but yeah like I'm
shallow I have my pick of whoo which
dick I want to so let me improve
myself you know get pecs yeah so I can
get my dick sucked
you know man we don't have to do that in
order to get our dick sucked when we
were like what are you into what books
are you read yeah gay dudes like I don't
care about yeah let me rub down
that oil on you I'm not only thinking
line is here you want to split a can of
coconut water you know my friend Jarrett
did this thing where he would like be
with the guy he's gay and uh and uh he
would say hey it's warmer in the bedroom
or or in the summer
hey it's cooler in the bed oh wow and it
was just on and that's global warming
that's that global warming tray yeah
yeah friction and then they go in there
you have left some ice in your bed I
mean that's a bit much guy huh um do you
think I just thought about this bro and
I don't know if this is probably this
might be gay or not and I might I don't
think I'm gay but what have you heard
you know yeah what I'm saying is
this do you think having a guy give you
a would probably be pretty
intense bro
cuz dude you are seen a duty something
real fast they're pretty quick bowel
plus just physically their throat is
longer oh they have bigger head kind of
scare him really get an extra like
quarter inch owe me this off blow job we
need that lady blow job yeah I mean are
their tongues like like I'm sure gruffer
you know oh yeah think about it bro
sometime you could if you accidentally
put two Kit Kats Nemo if you could
separate them with your tongue in your
mouth
yeah girls can't do that no no welcome
back alland women and have a friend help
break up you braid my hair why dude
that's it now that's what I bet if
somebody ever now of a man if they have
a man as homosexual and he convinces you
into getting you know oral with him I
bet he it's a I bet he once he once he
puts the jaws on yeah but it's a pretty
strong ever dude like really like make a
case for it oh yeah better oh my god
trapped in the bathroom on the way to
the yeah I was trying to do some airport
I was heading the airport but
everybody's doing cocaine
nice what in the at a party oh sorry I
stopped to drink something yeah but yeah
I was at a party and they had a man he
had some cocaine he try to lock me in
his bathroom and give me a yeah
and that made me nervous bro I was
at the rage once my gay friend mm-hmm he
called that whole strip of a la West
Hollywood Mecca oh yes we refer to or
doesn't Mecca I was in Mickey's and rage
or you know and um oh that's not a Libra
yeah dude I drove through there one time
and some bunch of nut hit the
windshield
oh yeah it's windy today yeah that's
crazy
yeah but he said he was pissing and this
dude was just like staring his dick and
he's like a new gay
Andrew Andrew and he was like he was
like can you not look at my dick and
they got it she goes yeah and then right
back to it like no don't crazy request
that is that's wild man but I guess I'm
just too bro that's the thing
dudes or slugs or slugs but I'll go in a
meeting sometimes this is when you start
to feel like I think what it feels like
to be women in some instances when you
go into a meeting
and the man in there is you know he's a
prefer he prefers the company of men and
you're in there talking to him and he
wants to you could tell he's like
listening to the show you're pitching
yeah but at the same time he's just like
you know all I can think about is just
you know rubbing it
oh yes just basking in the
Gloria you're nuts I would like
to say that's wrong but I've done that
too like me do I look at women in my
head once in a while I'm like I wonder
what oh yes if it's a boring pitch you
go yeah - now it was like oh yeah how
can I get this comb out of me
yeah dude that looks so much like a wig
it's crazy to puff up you got plus with
the side shaved oh my hair yeah it looks
I mean it really looks put on like you
like does it really yeah like this it
doesn't even look like oh yeah that one
or do the push up the muscle what dude
they had this lady named big Sal when I
used to work on this farm race we're
gonna farm in Mississippi and um and
they had this lady earlier named big Sal
and she was a lesbian
you know she was probably one of the top
story checks out yeah two lesbians you
know within about a 200 mile radius and
she one time or they had these kids and
were she worked at the same place I was
working at and we're going to swim and
the kids didn't know that she was living
it and we're just driving back to the
house and and one of them's like hey
let's go swim in big Sal goes oh I don't
have a bathing suit and one of the kids
goes all you can borrow my dad's and the
kids were young I didn't know every
brother yeah they were like five and
seven you know my brother lives in
Zurich so you know it's white oh yeah
yeah whistlin and uh he said but there's
some other you know braces in there but
kids don't know me but I remember being
a little and seeing a kid I was like in
seventh eighth grade I knew better but
then was seeing something like ten year
old pointing at a wheelchair guy long as
their mom's like slapping his hand out
but like look mom what's yeah you know
they don't know transformer they call
the transformer yeah but so anyway this
kid was like they saw this black family
was there in the neighborhood and
there's their little kid their
seven-year-old like mommy why is that
guy skinned wrong yeah quite
mommy's skin is black I should shut up
Wow yeah give me a trouble but the kids
don't know there's like that's different
than I'm used to yeah kids don't know
yeah it's gotta be wild I guess when
you're a kid I mean and now in some
areas oh now I think if you grow up and
they're teaching you about it like they
probably do in school here or maybe they
don't teach you in school about what I'm
like about about yeah somebody's gay or
somebody's you know a different
ethnicity or different you know I think
they do right I don't know but I think
they're like that they would so you're
prepared to see him they probably go too
far and teach you about stuff you
probably never even kind of contact or
do they think it's offensive to teach
about it now like that's the one thing I
probably but but right where I grew up
it was probably like I wish they would
have taught more like hey you know
people or they would have shown more of
the ways that people have similarities
in their lives and dissimilarities if
that's a word you know we're opposites
you know like they would have shown okay
well statistically these families have
more opportunity or these have families
make more money or these adventure if
they would have taught you that as a kid
I think you would have more of an
understanding maybe how things worked
yeah instead of hitting you when you're
35 like you're even like wait what yeah
yeah do you have black tires in your car
when you were young yeah yeah you should
have put the white ones on
didn't have white when the other did
you didn't look yeah you
know had those black people yeah white
walls yeah that's right
dude I remember yeah they didn't have a
lot of uh but I wish that me would have
taught us more when we were young you
know when they would have taught us more
or when kids were yelling during Pratt
you can I wish I would have spoken
Hebrew to me he never did really good I
would have known it really well so just
get by yeah why not teach Kittel a or a
second language yeah for sure think
about that all you got to do is leave a
radio one with some second
language company I don't have it you
just got it I know all the kids in like
rural Israel and like Akko and places
like that like they the kids knew fluent
English from TV yeah and the parents
couldn't say a word of it crazy well
it's also crazy to you see like second
generation Mexican kids and they don't
speak any Spanish doing and then we're
gonna we're like dude you gotta
learn even I know I gotta learn it yeah
I'm trying to learn Spanish now thanks
Russian Spanish because to get by and
like so
I'm rushin because you know soon we're
all gonna have to learn Russian yeah you
think that's where it's headed I mean
you know say in the law down man they're
gonna take over soon I wonder where it's
sometimes I start to wonder like I
started to think the other day that it
might be a good idea to go back to state
government I think it would especially
when you go to Utah and you realize like
oh you care generally the state about
different things and we care about yeah
and so it's like we're not all exactly
the same so I think they should have
more states rights yeah you know you
should vote on certain things like weed
being legal in California and then but
then like Connecticut sick well now they
are but like I don't know say I wasn't
we don't want that and say well don't
but I do want it so you do your thing
we'll do ours yeah instead of constantly
having because then there's less places
to put like people's arguments to it's
like it's not always this national
debate yeah I like move to a state where
that's cool yeah also if you like the
outdoors you talk Colorado those are
your state's yeah if you like no fire
Malibu California is for you yeah I
started too many of those fires last
last few years did you yeah I go over
there were cigarettes at litem upon
chairs kind of form on leaves
oh yeah Kevin Nealon does that oh really
yeah yeah he was saying again to that
with him mmm
create a perimeter that's what they call
it
you know perimeter of fire what do you
think scope so what do you what are you
feeling like with comedy these days do
you feel like we're headed back in a
direction where people are gonna say
whatever the they want do you feel
like we're getting more cornered
what do you feeling like I was feeling
like for a while there like it was
really tough to be a man I cried around
the election it felt very scary
well many days after the election
especially in New York that's a bubble
you live here it's another bubble right
so if people couldn't even comprehend
that Trump could have won right you know
yeah they could all your uh ninety-eight
percent and the funny thing is they're
looking for enemies in their bubbles
anybody you said this exact word wrong
like this ain't your enemy you're on the
same team here you know you got like two
percent on your team everybody go
somewhere else and find them but yeah
those three days after Zinn the subway
every dude was just sitting there like
like like not right now not a rapist
Yeah right and everyone was looking like
you Dan you did it I'm like I
didn't do it I didn't do it I didn't
vote yeah did you just come on me some
lady said to me just out of the blue
yeah I was like what are you talking
about yeah there were in a muffin like
these ladies are pissed
there's a weird thing with it we get
blamed for everyone
like we all get blamed for everyone's
thing and it's like they're like they're
like yeah it's kind of like I know
racists or Misamis Andres or whatever
it's like if I wouldn't do that to you
some guys would but I wouldn't so while
you're doing that yeah I don't
understand it and they look like they
said this my friend said this showed me
a bit of a clip of this guy at a music
festival in Australia
he came behind a girl and came in her
hair oh wow she was like man no
Australians yeah why am I in the
group why aren't the people who did it
you guys the men and women of Australia
not me
I didn't part of it I never came
anybody's hair no I did but now on
purpose you know strays yeah but you
know oh yeah some when you come you
don't know what's gonna happen yeah it
goes where it goes you know I honestly
think right now it's the best time in a
long time to be a comedian I think we
are now become counterculture for the
first time maybe since Lenny Bruce or
maybe since Kinison comedies cool again
it's Underground especially in New York
where you got to literally go downstairs
in most of the rooms to be in his
basements and people going in there
going like you they know the all
this stuff they hear about rape jokes
and race and gender and they're like
this comic might not just say something
offensive might he might be putting his
career on the line yeah that is
cool man it's like the Cotton Club back
then when Batman's parents got killed
you know yeah it's like this is some
dark and they're happy to be part
of it Oh some lady at the store then I
was like I heard I might even get raped
here and I was like why no but she's
like I kind of hope so his shop around
she's like I can't even raped in this
city anymore like that's crazy lady
that's crazy but yeah is it different in
New York and LA cuz you're back and
forth you live in New York and you're
out here a lot yeah yeah yeah it's a
little different but then you know the
store is different than LA to economy
stores its own subsection yeah now what
survive are people jealous of the store
I feel like because there's definitely
kind of a group at the store that is in
mmm-hmm and that is getting to perform a
lot I mean I I mean I'm doing better now
you know you know now that I have like
my Netflix special on Netflix double
negative or double negative and I was on
your show and unfortunately I missed it
oh this is not happening I missed the
one that it was right when you guys had
that fallen out oh yeah
and I'm gonna bring that up a bit but
also was trying to push the show ya know
a lot of good stories on there yeah a
lot of great stories on there just so
I'm just saying extra places you might
know worried from if you don't already
know him yeah what was the question I
forgot what the question was we're
talking about um oh is it different in
New York oh yeah well they see a big
scary store yeah it's like if I wasn't
doing those things I know that I
probably wouldn't be getting sponsor now
I might be grandfathered in from having
been there a long time yeah that career
is going better I don't know what I'd be
getting on but it'd be 11:45 12:30 you
know I mean there's no room yeah so date
yeah they see those lineups of stores
like Jesus but the one that when they
look at it it's like I say I'm a real
would look at it you know or Mike
Vecchio owner or some like Metzger big J
like well where am I gonna go in that
lineup so it's like it's cool they have
those lineups where's like a good now
relevant comic gonna go in there
yeah and where you want to some places
it's like you know like I usually get up
kind of towards the end of some of these
lineups and it's like man I don't want
to go out like some of these guys it's
scary to go after I call it early
because you can't get a workout anymore
there yeah it's a showcase room and not
a workout room yeah you know
yeah the belly rooms kind of become the
place to really go work out stuff so the
factory ain't gonna work out that used
to be the place where you try to get a
development deal oh you can go to that
room buy antique furniture to know if
you've been there recently but it looks
like an antique shop so so weird it's
all because that was the spot and when
the store was failing and nobody was
there I mean nobody was there we
wouldn't even start on time because we
kind of wait to wait an hour before we
got six people and like that's crap and
lows my mom's mobs every night my five I
can get in there I knew I could do
something yeah what's his name got that
development deal from the chick from
from a bird box she gave that Mexican
guy Sandra Bullock yeah she saw Paul
Rodriguez the other one Orlando labor no
he had his own TV show for a long time
you were in bird box oh Guillermo from
oh no no no she said Roberto yeah but
she saw a demo guy now he was really big
for a while oh yeah oh oh I'm thinking
uh who is it the Undertaker
who is it I don't know his name he's
makes a good Oh
one of the big heart oh this reminds me
how was it also her buddies
grandfather's funeral and there was a
magazine guy like helping dig the hole
and he felt it away I know I used to
work at a cemetery no did you yeah on
the National Cemetery oh that's oh
really I've been there oh yeah hey
beautiful it's gorgeous
we dig them and then when we were
waiting for the truck to pick us up on
those 90 degree plus 80% humidity days
we'd hang out in the in the open graves
why was it court-ordered hang out in
there no to be working there knows my
first job oh that's cool
6:36 an hour g1 damn yeah man it was
great we did were like you have to have
like I would a full cemetery or just
dude and you have the old ones like like
Abner Doubleday and Joe Lewis they're
all there with a big one but they have
grows and rows and rows of like those
those fallen soldiers you know yeah it's
gorgeous do you think it's like I
definitely noticed like obviously it's a
it feels like there's a softness to like
the youth these days right yeah but
do you think that's because we're so far
from a wartime that it's like they don't
like at least we would hear our
grandfathers or somebody talk about war
and talk about this you know a real wing
like maybe but we've been at war for the
last 20 years but in a way that's really
yeah it was just kind of this abstract
idea like I guess we're in Yemen I don't
know right just when I was still an
Afghan
you don't see like you would assume like
from like The Wonder Years when you see
videos and pictures of Vietnam on the TV
we don't really get those anymore yeah I
mean Bush said you know no no pictures
of the of the of the caskets coming home
and then and then Obama reversed that
but they still just didn't show pictures
of the caskets coming home it's like
they don't want us to have that ID
anymore that we're defending a country
that it's this George Lopez
Oh George Lopez really cool guy actually
I worked with him a couple times I
always thought he's very nice
I believe it baby way he was getting
deals out of the factory when I was like
why can I be there let's ride these
anybody complains like the economy
started have enough women it's like
off where were you and there were six
people in the audience yeah you weren't
trying to get in there we trying to
throw a show there to get people out of
the country
yeah I get on notice this the other day
women don't want to be upper drivers
like women are saying that you know
there's this opportunity you know
opportunity for dude I'd love to
have a lady pick me up
you know you think I do but it's not
matter you think I want a young gay man
handed me a butterscotch every day from
the front seat that's a little bit warm
and keeping the windows down while we
ride what the is going on dude I'm
in the back of a hooking man's car
eating a butterscotch with the windows
down dude and not getting molested bro
yeah baffling I mean that is why it's a
backseat like yeah I've had a couple
guys like why don't you Java get behind
you and I don't know man uber techniques
dude one time an old lady this Persian
lady she was the worst driver
her husband must have just cut her off
financially yeah and she was driving to
the airport I said man I said I cannot
it was unbelievable and she let me drive
and I drove us to the airport in
her uber no work yeah pretty
cool man and it was a Ford Taurus that
she had somebody paint into themselves
with like a like kind of a rose gold
color and like it was a piece of
you ever have a coked-up uber driver
yeah it's great they go through red
lights and I go and then back up if
you went up like you already threw it
man calm down like where you going I'm
gonna put an engines head down where are
you going I'm like I'm putting it in
just wait a second just keep going
you're fine through another Fred light
it's crazy like I do not put my seat
belt on like why why you put it on the
click of it makes it like keep quiet
down back there
five stars right show me show me
I was in uh I was in Illinois like rural
Illinois yeah and we'd eat we'd eaten
some acid right we got for these cops in
this convertible okay dude who is
wintertime right and so they're like all
right put the cup put the car put the
top up get home you know they let us all
Betty and realize we're on LSD right so
we go driving off we're all in these
back roads living it up and dude
the Sun is coming up and we find
ourselves on the exact same road headed
right back where the cops are
and they're still sitting there it's
like two hours later and we're like
no way the only place we could
not go is right here and we can't
turn around now see ya
so here's you can't see a confident stop
we're going after that yeah dude I
remember we put the top back down so we
thought there would be less car for the
cops to say is we buy so maybe they
wouldn't see us thinking maybe we were
making too much noise because this
everything makes so much noise on acid
and we were just give a row and they're
just like oh all went straight to jail
direct I got all three got taken into
the county courthouse
really oh yeah directly but bro the
moment were passing behind his
hope and they wait and hear us
probably doing four miles an hour with
the top down on the frigid
morning in rural rural Illinois that was
the last thing I heard somebody say
before the lights went up still refused
to admit you've done anything wrong
oh dude yeah we were in La Jolla the
Comedy Store not know me Rannazzisi
ain't kappa roll up oh wow best friends
forever tour just two gigs we ordered
280 t-shirts
I just we sold seven of them for myself
anyway cap had this rocket launcher it
was this thing this with oh yeah giant
like rubberband and you had this little
cradle on the inside and you have two
guys one guy hold it here and one guy
hold it there and the other guy just oh
for a boar char as you can't oh for
abortion be great but if abortion
launched it away we launched balloons
for a while we hit people on the beach
you stayed at that condom yeah right
here so it's far we can hit people by
the wake right and they they see
a balloon blow up at next time they're
looking around they're not looking 800
yards back oh yeah that's sure huh yeah
anyway we start launching her people and
then at night we're just trying to hit
passers-by on the boardwalk we hit this
guy and let his girlfriend he sounds
like a real you better
it was black but he was like Tony Gwynn
black oh wow I'm alone black oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah like Tony was like hey
what you doing in there
and we were like oh hi and it goes
comes right up to the balcony
goes deep ships I see you in
there I'm real I can see we're all that
crouched out he goes I see you one
behind a counter that's behind a chair
and we're like I guess there's a line of
broken balloons like trace all the way
back straight who are her balcony like
it's so obvious we're like eventually
just gets tired goes and
walks away was in La Jolla or
cyber San Diego and they had somebody I
was walking down the street I was with
my this girl that I was seeing and I was
they had like this cool store so I'll
just go look in the windows it's a
nighttime and there's just you can't
really see in there that good until you
put your face up to the glass and
there's two people right when I
put my face up to the glass yeah kind of
crazy
yeah dude one time my buddy got a
and middle of great junior high
school oh dude it works yeah and the
parents of the girl who blew him found
out and came over to my buddy's mom to
my buddy's house to have so the parents
could sit and talk about it right
because this is like the first
that had gone down in our town yeah so
dude I'm like bro you got yeah he put
the phone on if I could put it in the
living room with them is like Oh ro
knows when they first had cordless TV oh
nice so I'm just sitting there the
parents came they all sit in a living
room the mom got an awesome chaste or
something he's sitting in there
splitting a couple cans of Shasta
talking about the and in that
meantime while that was happening my
buddy and the girl went into the other
room and he almost got another
from her what's pretty crazy yeah you're
gonna stop that did my first people are
sucking dick probably the end of time
unless that goes out of business
yeah you're in her period you gotta
figure out you know or you just feel
like sucking somebody's day yeah I got
my first in a park
Sligo Creek Park oh yeah and it was at
night I went uh this girl I should marry
no I think but like she uh Tabitha
Tabitha Tabitha Jenkins Tabitha nah
so she got a I got a blanket put it out
there and she started well who brought
the blanket you were only dude she
taught me every way she taught me
everything I hadn't known that was
important she had tits or this chest
gia tits nose big no yeah man but she
was like she started blowing me and then
the cops showed up
oh yeah good night they like to watch I
never did anything like that before
and though excuse me and I just runs
like get away officer like walk away
this is not for you to stop it felt so
good oh yeah oh you dick feel like a eel
that never has met its family and so
what what is that yeah yeah and I was
Wyatt it is all you can hear yourself
getting joy yeah that's crazy huh
sometime a girl around the holidays put
a little jingle bell in her mouth yeah
the black girls would do that oh no you
got a little just something seasonal you
know something to keep everybody in the
mood you know what else is going on what
else do you think about the industry oh
I'd love to get more your thoughts on
the on the comedy and it's your Anna
that's interesting you've like we're in
a boom and that's in that it's an
exciting time I'm just about to go to
Australia for the first time oh you're
gonna kill it there really where you
going yeah we're going almost everywhere
I think we sold so we wanted to get just
me but um yeah me and my so I don't feel
alone okay but go on a Perth Brisbane I
would say hit Perth because there's no
more out there there's a nude beach in
Perth mm-hmm okay it's great
it's disgusting it ain't like the French
Riviera
it ain't fat gross I never liked the
French anyway there's a bunch of Joey
Diaz's oh yeah old imagine him in like
10 years and they'll check you out when
they pass but it's nice you're out there
just let your dick shine there's this
island right off that you could all do
with his quokkas Robben Island huh yeah
but here's what Nick Cody told me so
they're these dunes behind that new
beach and that's where all the gay guys
go to each other oh wow yeah
Schenley Park and right behind that
an sas testing ground so one guy in the
army his job was to go clear the dunes
of gay goods gay hmm it was a guy
stop sucking dick we're gonna launch
missiles now yeah and then everybody I'm
serious we're launching missiles in his
go up and down but they're hiding back
like I'm not gonna stop this dick
sucking you know it's worth the risk
ain't hitting every dude like a job ah
yeah you got to go scuba diving Great
Barrier Reef if you're there yeah you
that I did it last time it's worth going
to I'm sure I can give you a live aboard
that's there for like a grand like 3-4
days with the room where's a live aboard
you just live on board they take you out
way out because there's crocodiles if
you just go off and Kansas no you can't
swim this crocodiles so I can't just go
right off the coast into it uh-uh you
gotta go on a boat and they gotta take
you away from the Crocs geez but they
think it will round the other end of the
Great Barrier if you scuba dive it all
yeah oh for sure oh no I haven't where
he would have been snorkel you can
snorkel too or you can take lessons
while you're there but you can stick in
that place where you can snorkel really
oh yeah dude it's and that's my the
shore you got a boat out to that as well
no doubt but take it a few days at the
end of it Jeff Ross taught me that man
you could do a long trip like that take
a day or two to yourself to make it a
fun trip it sort of just a work trip
yeah you know so there's some cool hikes
in Perth like about an hour north two
hours north is these monoliths or
coolers yeah I'll show you
some stuff that you do they had a model
got a major neighborhood growing up we
always do named Sammy yeah and I told
him one time that he graduated high
school and he didn't and he was mentally
challenged and uh and now reacted uh-oh
he reacted great but it just set a hole
you just don't do it man you shouldn't
do that kind of because you can you
can adjust somebody's life you know well
then he thought he graduated well then
he would put up if his parents
trying to give him a school like a
graduated you know then he
started wearing all at ease I mean it's
silly kind of now but he started wearing
all these graduation outfits you know
yeah so he never grabbed yeah
and you never graduate anything and he
was mentally challenged so he was never
gonna I wasn't like I held him back was
here wasn't he that's a big question I
think he was do one thing that blows my
mind is if somebody's mentally
you nowadays they don't tell them so you
just have this buddy who's know who's
not doing things super great but doesn't
know why
you know yeah dude I'm telling you right
now and I'll shred in Melbourne and
Perth Melbourne is the most like woke
City mm-hmm but it's still nothing
compared to here really yeah all your
material the darkest you got they
will love it do they seem like such the
nicest and most of like amazing group of
people it seems like you're drinking now
or not drunk oh not drinking blowing now
or not nope oh well you're gonna have
trouble they're rude really oh yeah it's
a it's a it's a coke country oh wow it's
a coke country in a booze country so I
mean listen if you do relapse try to
leave it there because it's a tough
place it's a tough place not to get
anything like that's what everybody's
doing really yeah they do a coke over
there huh mm-hmm
mine is it was it look oh oh really
yeah it's my favorite they all do it
worst most expensive coke in the world
oh yeah
do that run yeah I'll hide
a kilo it had in my ass bro
it looks like the that they have
the least they list least instance I
think with one other country type
separate no belief in God so they don't
give a about sex they're like
thought let's okay
oh wow yeah even hitchhikers too I bet
probably it seemed like the kind of
place if people's nail hitchhike
that's the old route I always thought if
somebody smoked cigarettes they're like
yeah they're most likely to Oh
somebody's to say if they're down the
smoke they're down to poke I used to
think I would always hear yeah yeah I
think on reason a great spy what do you
think it is I think it's amazing I think
it is an evil about like the a
blog against you or some some Twitter
backlash but put it back lash ain't real
mm-hmm you know that's the thing Twitter
backlash is in real and that's why I
think let him let it be against you
that's great for you yeah a lot of these
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
anymore use it so quickly that people
aren't even watching dude the other day
I watched so Brendan Schaub and I do a
new podcast that King and the sting
yeah miRNA shall not do a new podcast
the king in the sting right Saab
yeah I thought it was sharp uh-huh he
changes dude his father was in the army
or something
oh really but here's the deal so we do
one I watched like 15 minutes of before
I've never watched it before and I was
like hole and it retained my interest I
was like man Park oh yeah and that's all
I mean I think it's hard you know and
you never like watching yourself but I
was like this isn't bad you know right
now he's got mental
oh yeah he got beat somebody he's full
or at least like Bordeaux I
thought I thought he tested if I'm not
mistaken I say I saw tester he tested
like just under oh yeah he
definitely he's come in second place a
couple times yeah yeah he has trouble if
the door says push and was pull he
figured that out I will stay in there I
saw I'm pressing the wall one time
saying it's not ringing no I was like
it's not a duel hell you know you just
got to have compassion just like you
know have patience with them yeah I tell
them he's telling me graduate it yeah I
don't know maybe it is good here for you
I feel like you're like this Oracle kind
of guy who goes around and gets this you
know you're like the guy hit the
messenger who goes out and gets the
information from different places and
come back and tell turns out the real
people we get this bubble of comedy be
like oh it's the end of everything I in
a at the end of anything
yeah the only real problem facing comics
right now or other comics yeah that's
the real issue and I've been a
I've done it too and it's I've been
embarrassed by it but like and so what
is that when we call when we call other
comics out it's just never a good idea
on their comedy because because the
reality is like whatever you want to do
when they're like oh you're doing jokes
about this like what you can't talk you
can't on topic you on
technique if you want but not publicly
yeah but on technique not time that
I wanna do a joke about flowers doing so
well flowers I wanna do a joke about
tinder do that I'm gonna do joke about
airplane do that but how are you gonna
do it that's an easier technique that's
what matters yeah not what you're
interested in how are you gonna examine
it you know if I want to do a pro racist
joke but if I can turn the crowd and
make them all laugh at me then that's a
great bit and that's the goal
yeah yeah the goal is laughter the goal
is in their tainment and that somehow
seems to be lost and I think that that's
where you know people got really pissed
with Hollywood it's like I don't want
you to preach me I don't want you to
tell me this I just want you to
entertain me that's why I pay you that's
why I lock dunkirk man helping man I
love Dunkirk I know
oh yeah dude top 60 movies ever I mean I
guess I like Tootsie as well have you
seen that that's pretty good shot that
yeah yeah it's just like whatever man
people say that's like it's brave to do
jokes or non jokes about
whatever am I gonna say am i his name
but like you know when they're just like
forgo comedy for a while to go on and
be serious about something I
think so
that ain't brave yeah that's not brave
there's not taking any chances you want
to be brave too today in 2019 do a
nine-minute pro-slavery bit yeah and get
the crowd allowed that's brave
try that and see how it the heads of
Korea that's bravery you're risking
something well yeah I asked the guy one
except one night in the front row they
had a black gentleman up there you know
and I was a you know I wouldn't I was
nervous but I wasn't wild you know and I
said hey man would you own a slave you
think honestly you're chillin at home
right a blood recycle block yeah I said
look bro be honest be honest you're
chillin at home there's a bunch of
dishes to do your wife's out of town you
maybe don't know how to do dishes or you
don't like doing oh yeah are you
watching the game yeah Sunday there's
three games in a row you're watching the
game in the game it's just two people
just kicking a ball back and forth
outside right cuz it's the 1800s all
right
somebody got a pack of marbles but still
you're watching the game and some guy
goes door-to-door was like hey got these
cool slaves and the slaves are cool
they're smiling you wouldn't you would
not where he hasn't put color on it yet
yeah just said people yeah we got these
slaves probably Asian you know Korean a
little you know some beautiful Korean
you know take a bus space as loves you
know yeah would you get one yeah I think
I would I think I treat it well but then
no I guess I am I would treat it well
for a while but then once they
act up you gotta lay the law down guys
you bring it on yourselves oh you think
I want to treat you like this you bring
it on yourself I want to be a good
master yeah I am a man of constant
sorrow like you would have been good in
that but yet here's the thing there's
something about you like you would get
if the guy didn't know anything you
would get a couple a badge if everybody
was getting slaves at the time of course
we get slaves you wouldn't you wouldn't
be the one who like I'd be you know more
woke than everybody based on my off
do you think you would be a good slave
be honest it well let me think
okay I'm not physically I'm not the best
I could do a lot of like mental work for
you okay you know like the way didn't
Shawshank whether he was like hey
you you route counting come you're gonna
work in the office the books me yeah I
wouldn't run I would accept that I have
no power I'd be pretty fast to that I'd
see somebody get whipped and stuff I'm
like oh I get it no I that'll happen to
me too right yeah right now I'm yeah I
get a killer enough to know that there's
no way out I might be looking for an
escape plan but I'm waiting for a while
and a few people escape and then see how
that plays I'm not trying to be the
front lines and escape yeah
you're not trying to be the
first guy out there yeah I think I could
easily do I always say ma'am to people
who were helping me you know not even
older women just like people to the
airport they're like do you ever tickets
like a Mega Man yeah I could be
respectful yes sir I get it you run the
household yeah well my dad taught me
well yeah I'm hoping to get a piece of
cake at Christmas I'm all the
better
yeah I know you don't have to do that
sir yeah I really appreciate that thank
you sure he's not my boy that's
crazy-making you it's just wow that
things happen but it's also it's like
something just goes one favor it's my
wife and I anniversary on next Thursday
could you just like just for one day not
rape her
yeah just that one day it'd be really
cool either that fresh morning with the
layout yeah just let me have a shot at
her let us sleep in a little I'm not
saying don't worry bro at all just that
one day yeah but a sleep till 6:15 a.m.
if you don't move it again if it's if
it's in a shoot yeah you know it's
obviously it's your call but yeah I
would love that
dude get out crazy that must have been
how much even know you cannot imagine I
can't imagine that date I would hate
that kind of I don't like getting
up early that much that would suck that
part would suck yeah I'd like to sleep
in I'll be like how about I'm like uh
like uh you know till 4:00 a.m. slave
you know I wake up at 11:00 that night
well I like the night you know
there's less distraction oh yeah get
more done you don't bump into other
slaves yeah you're right there on the
porch ready to rock yeah like a yeah
he's with ya they wake up in the morning
like what who bailed all this hey yeah I
did your honor
yeah yeah your I can feel even better we
got some calls that came in for you Ari
well it's had a couple of them yeah who
you pre-record them yeah we have people
that hit the hotline this is funny Oh
whole place man you got
Green saver art to slaves of
your own you're on that white plate -
what arrows that gay parrot that Sony
has closed oh man
where am i oh I see it and that isn't it
looks a little like uh it looks like you
actually some no program where's Grave
Fitzsimmons yeah there's Eddie Bravo in
the front monkey oh yeah
that's uh Bert Kreischer no it's Bobby
Lee oh yeah pretty good picture those
listening we'll put this painting on
Instagram so you can see it here's the
first question
okay go ahead vo re got a dark art
survivor here gang Georgia
Dorothy Oh already put our carts the
dark arts or things that take you out of
your element to succeed so excessive
masturbation doing drugs you know really
it sounds like Australia wait am i dark
art survivor if I do all those and don't
let it hold me back gang gang yeah
you're more of a Dark Arts master out
there yeah yeah cuz he I struggle with
it so I'm yeah I'm always the
guy who's up but you really seem
like a be a real savant like your
Slytherin oh yeah yeah yeah and I'm just
some Hufflepuff who keeps
you know cop in bags you know
yeah so but yeah you mastered the art so
is this kind of like proud boys but like
your own sect yeah oh no this guy was
just a guy who probably trying to stay
off for drugs and maybe trying to not to
jerk off at night okay that's cool hey
our dude do it in the shower yeah those
are a big nemesis's all right record
survivor here in Atlanta Georgia and I
have a question for both of you guys Ari
I know you got a second me this past
year through what made you come to the
conclusion that you never want to have
kids and Theo do you ever plan on having
kids gang gang gang gang baby there you
go let's gank from Juicy J what's that
from gang gang just white people trying
to be cool okay what made me
come to decision because man I take too
many chances
yeah you had too many chances yeah glam
rocker huh yeah and the odds of me
having a kid with the with a woman I
really like met and want to have a kid
with which by the way I don't
but if if that's the angle that I want
to go the odds of that happening versus
some skank in Kansas City that I
didn't even know her full name
some Muppet yeah and now I'm
through like the life with her forever
some zygote hustler trying to
rock that little bag of bones out of you
yeah the odds are way higher on hahaha
so are you coming in ladies or what are
you doing sometimes wow what am i I had
a lady once in in Annapolis I I can't
get pregnant oh hell yes and I came
inside her you know it was good and all
and then like a year later she's like I
got I'm pregnant with this other guy I
was like well I thought you couldn't get
pregnant she ever responded I was like
what I took such a massive
chance he can't believe somebody he says
you don't have any offers you Cameron
you gotta borrow you can believe anymore
that belief still yeah like oh I
got an infection of the I'll believe
anybody's I had a chicken Nashville it
was like I was like I'd like to okay and
I'm on an idiot so I was like hey I
don't have anything you know or I've had
like chlamydia in the past try to like
hit him I've had something you know yeah
I've only had two beers officer yes yeah
do you have anything I should know about
I didn't say like yeah my cool a condom
no big deal you know I'm telling where
it is but then I'm like hey if the worst
should happen I got a mouse trying to
get you pregnant but if it happens like
would you get an abortion just think you
know Quinn yeah quick Oh class today and
this chicken ash like oh no I would
never get an abortion look hot damn it
and then she was like to put it in for a
second I was like I'm doing this
well yeah cuz that's rather hood so Jim
painter always said couple clean strokes
there's not really sex yeah how many
strokes will you do how many strokes
before that will you pull out do you
have to be to feel safe there's
different times in my life Wow bro yeah
I've been I like pill over here dude
you're like John Henry this steel drop
you're going I've been one of those why
waste the best parts like the core of
the watermelon you know I mean it's just
you don't want to leave no you don't
want to leave like strokes on the table
yeah I mean if you're like me pull out
on about two comets like em you got two
good strokes left yeah the best strokes
as greens in regulation baby and I want
to be I just do a bit about but I want
to be that we'll pull out and go
I don't know I'm not positive yeah yeah
like do it wipe down like I don't know I
paid for many a plugin morning-after
pill I'll have you yeah with some dude
you should just put it in there
Oh attach it to your dick nope yeah
sneak it in yeah they say no with like
there's that tape that kind of fades
away that's that a surgical tape that
fit that you know
oh yeah glue or like I'm not glue but
that's the one you're going to get on
what's it called like stitches y'all
stitches are coming oh yeah in a
morning-after pill the morning-after
pill about your wiener yeah we got ribs
yeah that nugget on it and then other
times I'm like I'm gonna pull out like I
mean it's never far in advance I don't
understand how a porno they pull out and
then they just like stand over the girl
like this and then I can you and it's
like well you pulled out too early why
are you still doing this yeah there's no
cut should we pull out and go this
should be like no time that bust boy
yeah dude sometimes they have videos
used to be able to watch on pornography
where somebody had set a lot of base
with the bus so when they would bust you
but like mm-hmm
a lot different yeah there's just like
more base filled come you know you want
kids busting you know um yeah I'd like
some kids man I think about maybe having
four or five children ma'am what hold
you I'm 38 no I ain't gonna happen but
you don't think no in LA with these
vapid empty idiots I think I
would probably be a father now I'd get a
house in Nashville and maybe have them
over there yeah okay okay we adopt a
couple Latino kids maybe tops I would go
that's the other thing too like if I
wanted kids I I think a doctor I want a
couple or Tino's running around you know
what I'm saying
come a little magic little
you know sex a salsa you know
that's what I want ro about too you know
oh yeah bro can you even imagine whoa
somebody's like idiot man
all your friends are coming in chicks
yeah oh he's so cool man and I can't
just like his and just learn Spanish
from him have him teach me Spanish yeah
that'd be cool
well why would he know Spanish it's not
genetic
yes true well yeah somebody's gonna have
to teach him and then he's gonna
surprise me happy awesome
but yeah I wouldn't mind having some and
really it's too much work also like but
you own do you feel greedy if you don't
have them in what way not helping over
populate the overpopulated earth right
no it's greedy to have them but just
greedy you won't be able to have that
like emotional know what that feels like
to have like an emoticon child that's
greedy to want that when you know we're
overpopulated we know there's pound
puppy kids that need adopting oh yeah
I'm gonna go have your own kid that's
greedy but no okay so I want my I want a
new one
I'm gonna write a purebred dog
instead of saying hands about to be put
down
yeah I want a ginger yeah I wanna I
wanted to have my eyes yeah guess what
it'll have eyes it looks like a human me
and reg you're having a cinnamon one
it's like oh let's see what's going on
here but uh but yeah I think I do I
think but no this is interesting so I'm
trying to figure out if there's selfish
reasons why one one here's but what if
you think do you feel like you could
raise a child really well you seem like
a smart man I'll be a great to be able
to take care of great dog well I would
have been there and faked my own death
yeah like that well you do that just to
impress him
your dad was cool well Adam Egan said it
to me gets father you know it for the
comedy Holocaust denier was he really oh
he is though an HD he passed away though
his father no no Adam II get himself as
a hot customer look some people are dude
look it's like you know it's like
slavery they never found the boats you
know yeah he's always like style and
Stalin's yeah yeah yeah he doesn't think
I think he thinks like like like a few
hundred people died yeah one of those
like he's like something happen but it
wasn't a lot that's Morrissey if I can
feed him all that it was before
he knew the word fake news he was like
describing that he was like man
especially doctor I mean I think it's a
porn but yeah
I mean when you think about it he runs
the Commerce store and he's the one that
won't put any women up yeah a woman on
the line up in a month and this
Holocaust denier is the one at the yeah
Wow they should release better but I
guess it's a matter of somebody
start a groove Oh
someone should start a woman's hate
group yeah all those groups are hate
groups by the webs are not open blogs
hate groups yeah because all you do is
hate I've seen your blog's it's 80%
negative you're a hate group Jezebel
you're a hate group you what about um
what about now this sometimes with the
Holocaust it seemed like they have so
many everybody no no no they have it's
like look everybody's to survive for
every weakness another newspaper article
it's like a hundred and nine year old
and you're like what that guy's a
survivor that guy's Mexican you know
it's like they're starting to make it
like everybody like come on man it's
about my dad's a survivor but still
where did that father really 12 I think
what it did Wow yeah but like in Romania
but like yeah the thing is no one can
really tell right so yeah a lacrosse
survivor stamp this I become that PR
move where it's like you just say any
you could any person who's Jewish or
just looks you wish they're like yeah he
was a survivor and like he got hit by
lightning about three weeks ago in a
accident
why not it's like faking your own uh
anti-gay attack yeah no that's really I
kept this point on me I'm gonna call the
girls whatever it you know what I'm
a Holocaust survivor yeah going for it
actually I tell ya I'm telling this to
people who like Jewish chicks a Jewish
man who date who date uh
non-jews yeah and like well you know we
have to make them convert or they're not
gonna like be accepted into this
religion and I'm like here's a deal guys
just tell everybody you're Jewish yeah
just say my mom was Jewish
my dad wasn't and my mom's mom was
Jewish and her dad wasn't and we're like
technically Jewish and I'm like no no
there's no there's no system of checks
yeah so it's like you're just like okay
I guess you're a Jew big Jay oakerson is
a Jew you can't tell yeah you never tell
just say it who cares who gives a
about Jews what they think just live
them yeah get off your back
that's a Holocaust survivor I'm telling
you but I feel like do you feel like
it's harder to work in LA or it's easier
to work in Hollywood being Jewish it
doesn't that's a stereotype though we
don't look out
each other it's the only reason Jews are
big and I'm not a kid I'm asking that
because I've heard both sides of it I've
heard my friends say no there's so many
Jewish people out here that it's hard to
even it's hard to find a way to
differentiate yourself and then there's
also the school of thought that it's
like yeah well Jewish people help Jewish
people out okay so maybe so two ways so
the back bar used to have a couple Tighe
eyes working and then they would hire
pretty much exclusively Thai guys you
know that's Comedy Store yeah so in
order to get a job there it really did
help you to be taught yeah every time
yeah now another case black the NBA is
way more black than your normal standard
ratio of people oh yeah
but you can't be like hey I'm black and
you get me in there well it's not about
that it's about talent only right you
know I mean Jews don't hook up other
Jews because you're Jew because there's
plenty of Jews to pick from still ain't
looking for me right and also yeah you
ain't can't differentiate yourself cuz
there's so many Jews you have to
differentiate yourself on something else
right
like I don't funny or whatever else you
talk about yeah dirty or clean or you
know political comic take Smith's a
political comic I'm a filth pig
we're both Jews but we're not banking
off our Judaism we're banking off our
style right so if you saw if
anybody thinks that you think that's
just a fear that's a silly it's just uh
just anti-semitism was called is it
really hook each other up you kidding me
why do you think Jews are in Hollywood
cuz we're smart that's a bottom
line you guys huh why did you do well
we're just genetically smarter than you
I'd love to give you another explanation
for it we take care of our kids we value
education and we crush your financially
I don't know what to tell you
the only thing I can tell you with is
you can use this as an example better
your own lives that's as much as we can
help you work we're busy succeeding
off
Wow do you feel a lot of anti-semitism
nah yeah one time when I was in a bus in
Wheaton Maryland there were these two
pumper girls goth bunker girls behind me
and they were they had one of those you
know those birds go like this you know
and Joey too can know but that it was
like those DUHS like a little toys and
they would drink the water
uh-huh put a glass of water and they
would collect this oh wow that's neat
you don't know wha
you know what talk about right you're
calling it up it was from the eighties
drinking birth remember that it like
goes up you put some water tilt over
drink water and then we're out dude I'm
planet
anyway they bought one of those a
Wheaton Plaza and behind me mean is my
brother Robbie Schneider or somebody
they kept like hidden it to my yarmulke
yarmulke pecker yarmulke pecker and we
just sat there quietly like don't make a
noise don't instigate them and
they just came hitting my yarmulke with
his drinking bird toy that's
about as bad as it got no big deal
really
dee I feel like that kind of stuff like
is on the do you think it's on the
decline I guess I I generate more press
about that right I feel like there's
more press these days about bad stuff
happening there is bad stuff hat I know
and then they say that Pittsburgh
shooting you know would they shot up
that synagogue or Pittsburgh and people
like that's terrible and then Trump was
like it's because they didn't have armed
guards there and I'm like it's not shoot
have a conservative synagogue
because they don't have armed guards
it's so stupid yeah
the reason happening is because it
wasn't an Orthodox synagogue that's a
fake Conservative Judaism
what do you think was gonna happen when
the woman rabbi got protection
idiots you think he's gonna allow that
heresy to happen and just not
have you got shot it's per conservative
synagogue get a real mail rabbi like
you're supposed to cuz the Torah says
he'd be a judge you gotta be a man
sorry cuz it really oh yeah oh wow women
it's to be a to be a like a rabbi I'm
gonna be from the Torah it's considered
to being a judge women can't be judges
because the Talmud says women too
emotional mhm
yeah it's interesting now I mean
everybody tries to put like men and
women in the same boat and it's like
I've been thinking a lot about this
recently because we're just doing this
problem for Comedy Central and it's
about like one of the episodes was about
feminism right and Jim Jefferies came on
a moment and listen to some like slam
poetry and just you know some feminist
ideology and just different feminists
and some of it was really cool when
someone was you know gutter and
uh but it was interesting how like yeah
it's like there's this push to make
everybody like men and women you know
what that ever that were that we're all
that there's no real difference
oh right actually a story no is a clean
physically obviously there's a
difference although some people in like
college campuses like there's no
deference like we're bigger like yeah
but but do you think but so if there's
physical difference then there must be
like if men are bigger like if that's it
then it's like
there's other differences too yeah like
some people say nurturing is different
in men and women are though definitely
way people I don't have a sociological
people bully each other difference men
and women oh definitely
so like I don't know there's forces
differences it doesn't have to be like
you don't to quantify it as better or
worse right
but there's differences yeah women are
dumped cuts you know and men a really
smart intelligent like free thinkers you
know it's all it's all but ya know
better exactly Jim Jefferies yeah but
yeah I don't want men and women to be
the same now exactly so a lot of women
are like so they're split now so weird
the feminism split between like let's
say a basic thing like like okay in
divorce should it be you know alimony or
not you know should you pay child
support but like whatever the breakup
fee is and some feminists like no
that or make an equal money now you
don't pay us anymore we're not
as housewives it gave up our careers for
that I'm a lawyer you're a lawyer you
don't to pay me and other women are like
that men have abused us for years
we want that and so we're going like I
don't want your messages some women are
like stand up for me in the subway other
women like no my legs work off yeah
be fine yeah but everybody else no in
fact I have less weight to pick up
because I'm 5 3 you know 112
pounds of anything I'll stand up for me
yeah I'm 185 and overweight yeah I mean
I need my legs to work I can eat
standing up a lot of these women
are saying you know it's crazy yeah it's
different man I just worry that women
would be inspired but I'd like to be get
out there and believe this man lifestyle
that's not that great and then
they're gonna be lonesome because they
don't end up having families which i
think are things that people enjoy well
I think it's when you talk with in a
binary world we're like women want this
instead of like there's their multitude
of let's get on to it where it's like
somewhat just like you you want a family
and part of you doesn't probably likes
being single part of you wants a family
and it's like different men want
different things I definitely don't yeah
you lean towards it so it's like
everybody's different and everybody puts
in is black and white like women want
this men want this and the reality is
people want what people want why do you
think it's afraid for us to escape
sometimes what our ID like we have an
idea of something you know huh like
sometimes it's like yeah it's like this
needs the way a marriage needs to be and
a family needs to be and then it's like
when you start to think that maybe you
might want something that's different a
little different alternative or
something anything different
polyamorous relationships now and I get
scared sometimes to even think about
some of that because I feel like it
could work well I feel like it could
work maybe but also yeah I don't know
why that kind of stuff scares me I'm
scared to watch anime porn yeah
because what's that the drawing yeah oh
yeah I've never watched any but I feel
like if I didn't I got into it would be
like it would just be my whole life
after that oh wow you know I want to
lose myself to it same reason so
everyone takes mushrooms cause like I'm
afraid I would like lose control do it I
turn to mr. McGregor and get lost boy
yeah start letting that let that
rabbit run through your garden notes hit
another one right here
let's hit another question that came in
for Ari Shaffir my question is this you
wanna your mom's house shirt off
here's to children to living with him no
he doesn't bless I want on the record
Tom Segura doesn't Moses own children
only other people's children yeah so
please don't take that out of context go
ahead so my question is this get your
legs both of you seem to hate st. Louis
he went on for like a minute after that
I cut him off what'd he say why do you
guys both hate st. Louis it seems a
little seems like you said I know
there's no good comedy club there yeah I
almost got my I didn't get molested but
I get somebody you know a couple guys
touch my ass at once in a Ramada there
in an elevator East st. Louis and they
had a a shady you know Donny grins or
some halfway house
comedy closed on the second floor of a
Ramada really there's a last time I've
been there yeah damn yeah I got no
problem with st. Louis I went to a
wedding there without with a with a dude
who had Tourette's oh yeah yeah he
wasn't in the wedding but he was up in
the front I didn't know and I just heard
this like book and I had no idea what it
was well yeah and I asked my friend I
thought it was like duh I thought it was
the violin guy like up for real
I can if I think I broke a string and I
asked my friend I was like who hired
this guy there's no man I got Tourette's
up there and I had to laugh so hard but
you know like when you can't laugh but
you have to but it's a wedding you tell
yes great just held it I was like
and then he starts poking me
trying to get me to laugh at my friend's
wedding and that just more and more and
then the guy keeps going but he starts
cursing and I'm just like looking down
trying to like tune everything else I
was like balls as they're
like beautifully walking down the aisle
you know and I'm trying not to laugh
things just going Jews Jews Jews oh I
lost him I couldn't hold it anymore I
lost it I was out I had to leave the
wedding you got a war people man I yeah
you do we had a guy in here who beat it
he said he beat it
what did he do he beat tourettes he had
it and then he shook it literally I
guess but yeah if I couldn't have it
anymore
yeah does he really but like yeah
that's it oh did I see Mikey as an IE as
an idea they didn't fully forward maybe
maybe I sneeze it went away they are
their ideas that you if people get that
other people don't get like some like
blank people get sickle-cell anemia
diseases like some at Jesus tay-sachs
disease Tay says yeah you have to if you
get married to a Jewish person gets
married to another Jewish person gotta
test it because if you're both carriers
there's a 1 in 4 chance you're dot your
child will die horribly before the age
of like 12 years old Wow like mangled
and gross so I just don't get rid of it
don't don't even don't even have don't
even get married and get rid of this
relationship if one's a carrier one's
not then there's a 1 in 4 chance your
kid will be a carrier but that doesn't
do anything and then if you both have a
sex I mean uh yeah a sex ed and you'll
both be dead so you won't get to that
point damn yeah that's crazy bro yeah
Tay Sachs is a Jew only disease yeah you
get all this intelligence everything
else goes to damn do you think you
could have survived the Holocaust or now
uh in America I could have
uh-huh no I would a good kill for sure
really for sure
I don't think so man I think you're
underestimate yourself dude I think you
could have done it why you just seem
like you know people like you you seem
like well you're outspoken though so
that might be you might have had to be
kind of quiet when I put my mouth
you'd have to be quiet guys even know
that you're not even like killing people
like the in the best way you you're like
lining them up you could hear if you
lied I'm gonna get two at a time you can
save bullets you idiot oh I never
gone
yeah yeah I'm too outspoken I put my
foot in their mouth so much I think more
than most comics well I just can't help
it but to be honest and like share my
opinion yeah but that's great though I
think that's what makes you a comedian
that you know that people love that
people can rely on they they know they
can go to you to get exactly what you're
thinking yeah I were I'm not gonna be
dishonest at worst I'll be quiet but I
ain't gonna like lie about something
yeah did your dad ever get you give any
pointers on how to survive the Holocaust
or something like that
no I wish you would have he didn't teach
me Hebrew or how to survive the
Holocaust when that happens again so I'm
really a Paul a little bit on both those
things should is really tick over the
Germans take over I'm really do
you think there's a state in America if
there was a state war that's really
gonna have a really best shot of winning
I mean you know that's a good question
Callie's got the Mexicans but New York's
got these Dominicans and they're tough
bro gotta have water up and get wet than
nothing oh yeah they jump in bombs in
there and they're not black oh yeah
that's race brave bro yeah but if they
don't even think that I've been trying
to push the boundaries they're just like
that's how we talk yeah yeah wonder who
I don't think it'd be like North Dakota
or something like that neither people
need the people yeah yeah I think it'd
be New York we have a lot of Jews a lot
of Jung of Florida's hell are Jews
but they're retired they're done I think
New York got a lot of Jews who are smart
and we know how to grunts so the Jews
would lead the grunts they they'd be
willing to accept what's the acceptable
casualty but it's American Jews it's not
Israelis it couldn't mean uh Israelis I
feel like are tougher oh yeah American
Jews would like run it like like the
books holiday would organize it's like
how many people because they'd have the
planning yeah we wouldn't be doing the
fighting would be doing the planning
directly exactly be officers straight to
officer school yeah I mean I don't think
it'd be California has a lot of people
on it's big it's got the space
Alabama's a lot of black people so does
Georgia yeah but they're like yeah I
don't see it they didn't do for
slavery that's true they didn't get
together always if you go to Africa
they're not really a dad they're not a
lot of there's not a lot of bill on the
same team yeah give it here about
Liberia the history of Liberia it's
after like slavery ended you know
they're like a lot of blacks were like
let's go back to Africa we're not wanted
here
and so President Monroe was like I'll
ship you guys back if you want I get it
we've been we you guys up do you
want to go back there I mean like we
were born there were six generations
here ten generations whatever it is he's
like I get it but so they went back and
they found in Liberia Liberia since
we're liberated oh wow yeah and their
capital is Monrovia President Monroe
I think seyis English that's cool yeah
they're big timers Charles Taylor
normal Americans down her name
Charles Taylor that play for enough
49ers I don't think it was Sam I think
there's a different one could have been
I gotta look into it might have been the
central to is that Charles Taylor Who am
I thinking of Jamaal Charles no hmm
that's crazy I should go there's
something I want to go my friend Liz
from there oh yeah escape while that's
while the the war was going on he went
through the university Maryland with me
mm-hmm
but he was like wars over we can go yeah
Saul family there I was like yeah I want
to go there that sounds cool as I
don't know anybody's been in Liberia
that's crazy except Jesse I'd love to go
yeah right dude you have so much fun and
goddamn Australia Perth nobody goes the
first on our first trip hey I'm rate I
might get all Clint as well I shouldn't
have said that
why because now if I don't go it's gonna
be really people gonna be uncomfortable
listen here's the deal no matter what
the like you better than Tom Segura was
cancelled two times on them
we bought tickets saved up money bought
tickets and then he pretty much said
you he I think he had to shoot him
move with iliza shlesinger
no worst yeah lies in TIG he was like I
really want to work with us in the no
worst month of my life yeah and so
instead of that what was the movie about
fans what was the movie about
forcing thing I see about angry about
let go move on yeah yeah fortunately
things yeah dang yeah somebody said
there was a lawsuit with TIG Notaro and
Amy Schumer did you hear that a lawsuit
what do you mean I don't know I just
heard that about who got stuck that
I don't know and I shouldn't I don't
know that a lawsuit I just heard
somebody talking about that the other
day I don't know what it was about I'm
really like each other let's uh let's
get another couple of questions man I'm
trying to think of anything else that
I'd love to talk to you about alright I
mean the crazy thing is you let me come
see your place one time oh yeah which
was really great in New York and not
happen story that's when I started
getting sober - right then it's the
basis of that story you're told
yeah hook him out yet oh yeah came out
huh and they had it they have a they had
a name
right down the street there from your
place and you gots over there after that
well I would start going to yeah I mean
there were times where there was no I
didn't feel like going far and I would
just go to the one down the street and I
lost all your house keys I locked myself
out of your house three times lost all
the keys had to hire a company to make
him a new new doula the new door lock
new keys but I did it
yeah but the cool thing with that is now
my landlord does not have my keys so we
got an expectant mom I'm not gonna be
there like they can't get in there oh
wow never get my keys okay you did that
did all the blow in New York while you
were there lost my keys so hey I did
find a new way I did when it is when I
came home from I was gone for a while I
think yeah you're gonna just you know me
like land I just want to go home like I
couldn't I just stopped by Michaela's
house oh yeah and get my key and then go
home and try to coordinate with her even
with all that you were still one of the
best house guests I've ever had really
cuz Luis Gomez stayed there and it was
all I could do not to steal the money I
left out huh yeah he was bragging about
what a good house cuz you know $134 I
didn't take any of it I'm like you know
supposed to brag about that why'd you
count my money yeah cuz you were
thinking of the whole time they Smith
said that say that I left him an eighth
of weed I was like dude you can smoke
all this leave all the I brought
from California it's in Ziploc like
airtight pouches it was all down to like
the nub just like little piggy like open
up everyone and just took a little bit
at a time like I wouldn't notice but I
haven't been home
so one from a full ounce down to
gram ah yeah both garbage awful
houseguests you even with all that
you're second best in Nick Cody oh think
he was good he was good he left to clean
but you gave me that that the
soda maker soda maker yeah and I think
you did that because though the
airstream is a Israeli owned company
that really kills Palestinians or
something do they really know but I
remember they got mad at Princess Leia
you know that put the 2001 Princess Leia
what's her name she's Jewish right
Carrie Fisher
no no no the 2001 Princess Leia Oh evany
know what for sure her name was not
ebony I don't know anybody Riley he was
Michael Landon fan shoot some clothes he
was Jewish Michael Landon yeah Wow when
he played a Christian priest
version angel he was half and half I
think happen HAP's a great mix don't you
think but she did a shoot some closer
also half a half is a good books she did
a commercial for SodaStream and that
they said it was a so
obviously like why do you support murder
of Palestinians who's like wait what I
just wanted bubbles in water put me on
the record for that's a problem with the
left these days they don't just put you
on the thing you stand for they put you
on anything you're a yes you're friends
with this guy you associate with this
bike associate what do you what does
that mean no what do what I do
did they just called out that guy Chris
Pratt he went to church right so he goes
to church he has some faith and they
made fun of the church that girl Eddie
Eddie pay not even a tidge Ellen page
ripped him up you know it's gonna yeah
she's like well that church that you
know hates LGTBQ well I don't write so
maybe I'll sway over the church right
I'm back to normal it's like how do you
expect anything to change if you aren't
willing to see that people can be
different you know that's one
understands we're not all some people
just want a place to go yeah what can
you do there's only a couple of options
only like six or seven religions maybe
it's close to his house maybe what he
was raised in and also if you go like
associate with something terrible that's
like well you live in America and
they've murdered a six-year-old Yemeni
girl like a month ago so like you
associate with that you stand for that
like no I live here but like when they
put you on the record like yeah I guess
you all do everybody here it's great
responsible for the murder of a of a
young woman and what makes people do
that what makes people say what makes
people do that I wonder why do you it's
it's it's just sure you want to
win arguments without actually learning
anything they want to like act better
than you you know that's what it is I
want to act better than you so I'll put
you in a place it's morally bereft so I
can be like I'm not that yeah even
though you're not that thing so it's
like dude I love this scene here
because it's right here right like
across right where I'm standing over
there was mouths Chinese one of the best
choice yeah I've been here's one of the
first tiny place ever went yeah you got
a you've got a ass ports
on the menu
here's 2001 check from close what
England what the who the was that
who was it uh Davis homies in rogue one
sorry I figure I just bought was a Geena
Davis once not 2001 that Star Wars
Episode one with to that girl remembered
a girl never Rock notice what was that
movie with Rocky Denison
you know masks I love that movie yeah
yeah a different movie but both movies
for sure you know her name
she's all out my name we'll fight it
after the class look up closer okay go
ahead alone my lords quick question have
either of you guys have ever made a joke
that you felt bad for making and if so
what was it
shout out to the amazing racist Gang
Gang there you go
okay loves you man thank you for your
question brother um have I ever made a
joke that's a good question a joke that
you made that you bailed out on bailed
out like stop you felt bad about oh
right
Natalie Portman yeah but she wasn't
Princess Leia was she is the woman I'm
blow-up pear ounces to her that's for
sure I lost out
yeah there's stuff I felt like bad for
like I used to joke about like real fat
people you know we had you know like
move your legs around each other like
straight up you like get him around each
other yeah and I would do it for a while
I was trying to be like like that man
yet he like carry the one almost like
you're doing multiplication there you go
get the yeah um but then I
remember seeing I could obese woman in
the audience and be like oh I don't want
to feel bad I was kind of trying to
laugh at someone's expensive wasn't here
yeah another you're here I kind of felt
that about it but like I'm not sorry I
do it that's how I learned to become a
comic where I can like find the line
that I have right you got to go over it
you know when they tell Andre Agassi how
to serve they tell him at her as hard as
he could and then they tie my to aim if
they stopped and were like well that
ball went out that's no good yeah he
wouldn't have hit hard it's actually
really good point yeah it's like you
start to know what your line is and
everybody's line is gonna be different
for their level of color you're wrong
they are moral compass and people are
gonna start to know that over time and
they expect to go there and see someone
who's mastered exactly what they're
doing and it changes while you change
and what you get into you know so it's
like yeah there's been jokes I've been
upset up like I've been like man but not
that many mostly I'm fine with it
ya know it's not about like who's
offended but it's about like what I feel
how about you yeah I think I'm trying to
think of anyone that really uh or if I
don't believe in the premise of their
joke that's that I'm hurt that hurts
more not if I'm offending anybody but if
I'm like if I say something I'm like
not into like if I make a wage gap joke
but I don't really believe the wage gap
is will they're making it out to be oh
yeah then I'm like no one would be
offended by this but I don't think
that's true and I could rework I could
have rewarded it to make it still work I
saw Willie Barcena do that once we did
joke about being poor but he was like a
hero in the Latino world where I saw him
at and he was he just made it when I
used to be poor yeah so now it's honest
mmm instead of pretending like you're
still poor now yeah yeah I think I'm
trying to think if there's any specific
I'm sure I tried a couple that did not
get some laughs for sure and that made
me think okay this is too much
oh well there's that too I mean I don't
like not getting laughs so but I'm not
sorry I do it it's just like I didn't
know how to do it right yeah you know I
think in the beginning Isis definitely
say stuff that was more like low common
denominator and like shock for the
sticker shock
yeah shock I didn't know what else to do
I didn't have any real doesn't even know
what I was doing really I was just
trying to stay safe up there mm-hmm
you know and stay okay yeah but that's
me that's the worst thing now is staying
safe yeah all right
I want to get more edgy now I think even
just listening to conversations like
this and thinking about it like you know
in here and like you know this is a good
time for comedy and like you can make
them laugh at something they don't want
to laugh at yeah he's like yeah man
that's that yeah that's that beautiful
trigger and here's a here's a white
right here with a question that's not
what yo are Ethier what's happening man
immersion clone Ian from Port Douglas
Australia modulation for re well this is
a Maori could you please elaborate on
that salvia trip he had back in the day
back with the old red band I believe you
said it felt like you were living under
water for four months to two years
there's a bit elaborate on that and be
pretty pretty cool is this sounds pretty
interesting there's a problem that's
dicey question okay did a lot we're not
that's why he's getting that I went in
took like five full minutes and he's
getting that and he's pretty much that's
the question like I want to hear you
talk it's a dumb question bro we get
another if we just want to move on or do
you want to get into it I mean I took a
heavy salvia truck it's been along how
much is that like a couple hours no so
we took a bomb what is it come in a
little pal Kit Kat how pouch you can get
him at Circus of books that on a Santa
mom you really cinema yeah it wasn't
illegal I might have made it legal since
then but one of those under-the-radar
drugs and you process it 20 times
waiting times 60 times even eighty times
more processor was the higher the higher
potency was read band was into it and
yeah I think I'd done it once before it
makes you like lose your balance
start seeing stuff from like childhood
and the color yellow a lot oh yeah
anyway so we're doing it on a podcast
and I took a big hit at up out of a bomb
but I wasn't used to like smoking like a
lot of people go like you know when you
see a ball it'll clear at all then yeah
I cough I could half a bomb here then I
got to do the rest of the bong edge weed
so I did as much as I could and I was
like start coughing but they were like
that wasn't a full hit but it
got me to where I was like like right on
the line it was shook so I was already
like got a head start on it like do a
real hit and I was like ahh I was like
about to trip out and then I did this
massive which would have been plenty the
first time but I did that in conjunction
with the other hit and you went deep I
was gone
oh yeah I mean I was not there anymore
couple of orphans driving your
brain yeah I guess I was laying there I
don't know how long but like so then I
started living in this like underwater
in his lake behind my child at home I
was just there
I had a life my friends I had a job I
had this woman I had a relationship with
oh wow
and it was like it went on and so I said
I I don't remember exactly but it's I
would say somewhere between six months
and two years
mhm I was down there you know and you
know sports teams were doing well all
underwater you know in its underwater
land we're all like sea horses and
came in one day you know breathing water
fine
one day I'm swimming up around and I
just see right out of the water right at
the edge of the water probably closes
we're sitting right now that's why I was
just act out and I say the edge' Lara
dude a human dude oh yeah what and was
Sam Tripoli Wow
and I just swim up to him I could see
him being somewhere I like there yeah I
mean he was there in the room with me so
but that's why I was like starting to
come back eight nine ten minutes later
and I was like what the is that and
then I like kind of popped up but it was
Sam but I wasn't all the way back yet
they gave me some water and I just had
to spin it up cuz I was like no you
breathed water you don't that's amniotic
bright you got all amniotic yeah and
then I was like another 15 minutes so I
was like back again and I was like I was
like wait I'm not here it's kind of like
Inception you know
belly in her back way no no oh oh yeah
oh yeah this is this is life yeah but I
thought I had a new life I thought she
was out there that was it good that was
a good trip it looks shitty look like if
you see the video ever cuz ribbon taped
it it looked pretty awful but it wasn't
awful man I'm a crybaby the McRib is
back son that's what it sounds like he's
a good tiger I'd do that again it's a
dirty drug is it yeah it's so dirty that
coke is a dirty drug yeah mushrooms and
acid are not dirty you know
MDMA is I don't know what about that DMT
have you done it
it wants I didn't quite get there you
don't never done it I'm gonna do it
again I did it I was in my backyard I
you know I have that fact oh yeah I've
been out there smoking cigarettes before
yeah that's great it's the best part of
my apartment yeah it's nice dude I so a
couple times when I got locked out I did
go over that garden that's called
buildings down I'd have jumped the fence
into that garden go through the garden
and then jump through the back areas of
the other between that building between
you and that garden area to get to you
luckily left the door unlocked
yes Wow cuz it seems fine to leave it
unlock it's all fenced like who would go
there the rich people next door
no why did you get those three times I
was crazy
middle of the night three I mean
somebody black what the you doing
call the cop I was so nervous day jumped
yeah that's great
this yeah kid not hold on those
keys man yeah so I was lying that next
this girl we smoked some DMT hmm she was
gone I was like going and then I was
laying there in that tree saw this uh
this caterpillar oh yeah this hexagon
like like like things made up of a
caterpillar come down to the tree and I
was just looking at it
and he looked at me for a while and I
looked back at him and then he just goes
no and then just like caterpillars back
up the tree and I was like I was out of
it I was like what that looked at the
girl and she was like I just died and
came back to jus and I was like no I
don't think I got invited I'm just like
oh you missed out Wow
yeah he said no wasn't ready I guess Wow
yeah I got to do it again I have some
mother nature came looking for you
anywhere I'm ready for now so you know
in fact maybe maybe in uh in Phoenix or
in Phoenix and Tempe and Miami in West
Palm maybe maybe a toughy in Phoenix
maybe but maybe a fan
me something I can do something with the
Adrienne smoke some DMT who's a
junior lady no Adrienne a pallucci opens
for me sometimes there's a real dark
comic from New York oh yeah I met her
before yeah and uh I got her high in
Austin she's cool chick she is cool but
she doesn't get high much and she
started being convinced that I was gonna
kill her and that's why I invite her out
there and she couldn't get it out of her
head and I saw instantly and I'm like oh
I already been through this with other
friends there's no way I can convince
you because of course I would really
kill you yeah so every time I was like
oh I took the wrong way the wrong way
where are we going I'm like agent I
could have killed you anywhere yeah I
don't need a good long ways all this gas
money you would have to out the house
well that's like Shane Moss was on here
he ate a bunch of drugs right he went
you know he got all buzz also Moss goes
for yeah dude and he uh and he hired a
film crew to make a documentary and then
he thought the film crew was stealing
his life and secrets so he started
giving clues to the camera that he would
then watch later down the road so that
he would be able to know what was really
going oh man he went to the hospital Wow
yeah we did mushrooms every day for a
month tried to do mushrooms every day
for a month but then right when he
started he apparently somebody might
even do some DMT and he agreed to do it
and it was just too much at once he said
holding himself with this that
wouldn't let it come out of his pores
yeah
something root and so uh then it just
like kept circling around in his body he
got caught up well that's the dark art
dude I saw him a month or two later and
Pink Floyd Roger Waters concert in in
like yeah he invited me and my lady and
was great it was a great concert but he
was like he hadn't taken anything for a
while but the way he was talking was
like that that you know that 30 minutes
to an hour after you come out of your
mushroom trip and he was until kind of
half there and half there he was talking
like that all the time
oh yeah he's still there a little bit
he's still a bit of a loose stool if you
ask me what else do we have here for mr.
Ari I did that lime bit cut some DMT
once mm-hmm
not CMC sorry MDMA once and from one of
the store dealers at the time and I
remember like I hadn't taken I was like
where's ecstasy that's what it was well
just like hazard in there and I was like
in a Vegas casino with Eddie Bravo and
Rogan and I'm starting to feel like
oh
it might be taking too much I might OD I
remember texting myself I got these
drugs from Sandy damn toe so if somebody
if I died and somebody found my thing
they
like jail for what he did to me as he
will should who would win in a fight
between you and our Bert Kreischer do
you think it depends if I was smart
about it if I ran around a little bit
and tired him out from his fat then he
would I would win because he would just
fall over yeah
actually no he's listen I make fun of
him a lot but I've consistently
underestimated his athletic ability I
gotta believe he if he grabs me it's
over it's over yeah I can make him laugh
maybe but if you tickle to my thigh Kiki
yeah that's the way I think that's
something like that I think something
like that he wouldn't expect it or plead
like oh man no I have a girlfriend and
everything's going better for me please
please yeah and then he like let go and
then I couch yeah I be Jory than him or
if you asked him how many girls he slept
with and he said six you know everybody
always says yeah he always says six you
know what would be good fight though
yeah it'd be tough I have some jujitsu
training a little bit at you proper
white belt but I don't know how much it
would do against that wait are you sure
we had a vote on it a lot of our users
voted for you I'm brilliant but you
hundred fifty eight pounds though all
right here and be it pounds or what a
flap dude that stomach goes out more
than a pregnant belly just didn't
there's no there's no like juggle - it's
just pushed out like a second trimester
baby let's get this one last question
here for Ari Shaffir who who is this
here Nicolas Andy Phelps okay my name's
Andy from Salt Lake City my question
would be re looks like if you weren't
doing stand-up comedy and if you had to
work a blue-collar type of job what do
you think it'd be whichever work a
blue-collar job was talking about I mean
if I wasn't me at all you're saying what
what kind of blue-collar jobs are good
for blue-collar people yeah I'd be a
lawyer first of all but wasn't a comic
but what's a blue-collar job you had be
something with your hands it's like what
a juggler no I think I don't that's the
collar job is oh yeah maybe I guess what
else may be playing bow and arrow I
don't think that's what the post office
yeah I think that's more what they mean
like that blue-collar job
yes Shoveler yeah I wouldn't do anything
like that I think I'd be like Foreman at
a
I mean let's assume I steal who I am so
I'm pretty intelligent yeah I think
forming at a construction site
blue-collar Drive something like that
yeah maybe out maybe I own a uh uh like
in Long Island I don't like a contractor
like a contracting company yeah what do
you think about Long Island they they
they had that Amazon going there and
they're down they're out now
well that's Long Island says pretty much
greater New York actual Long Island it's
garbage visits for garbage people I'm
trying to come up with a term a lot of
hotties over there though huh
mostly not really oh yeah well I guess
I'll picture the hot chick that one yeah
this couple come out of there a lot of
twinks over there too Bert Kreischer
actually won this 53 to 47 was a
percentages votes I mean I would vote
for Bert also in your own fight against
him yeah but that I see you being a yeah
that's calculated oh I'm definitely
gonna be smarter about it I'm gonna like
dope all anything I can always in him do
we do that weight loss challenge or that
Fitness Challenge
they were like orient worked out for
three days and we're beat and we're
lapping them and then Brogan's like dude
are you not going online with your
device so you can like put a bunch of
stuff on at once and I mean how does not
work out because we think we're ahead of
you I'm like of course idiot
yeah what do you think I just wasn't
working out letting you win yeah
obviously I'm sandbagging did
you win dime yeah the only person
who beat me was disqualified for steroid
use
Wow Joe Rogan yeah I think that's who it
was yeah but yeah I was the it was the
nan Barry Bonds winner of sober October
for sure wow I love that man yeah that's
pretty cool what was that last question
that was it blue collar gap oh yeah what
would you do that a blue collar I'm
we're gonna follow him that'd be pretty
good no you know what I think I would do
that I think I propel
I have a company preparing people for
their puffs for the zombie apocalypse
oh well like that zombie prep with Ari
Shaffir yeah damn that actually sounds
like an amazing summer webster's summer
camp summer camp yeah yeah yeah is it is
there something a lot of Jewish people
like to do blue-collar jobs but you
worked in a graveyard
that's 16 right for a lark feel my hands
man that's someone who has not worked
hard as hold until the death in them oh
so what is that it's just like a it's
just like a thing like ooh yeah it's not
for us it's like to be the organizers
yeah it's for cogs man too
you're smart for that listen guys I know
I get how this will get taken we're
smart I don't know how to tell you're
mad I don't tell you in a few
generations you can get there if you
work hard but you won't work hard you're
gonna burn your families and do a
bunch of blows and do like that but
look Stan they're Koreans I'm right with
you
or if you see would you call Chinese
people are sort of the real black people
you say that's why I can say you're
wrong what way let's break this down
he's Chinese people man they love to
barbecue real as bro realest
rims on everything really down
the China Shaolin is like China
they are the closer to their immigrant
status but they're real as hell bro if
you get some real ass Chinese people
black guys nail do you not have a black
forum the other day told me he's dizzy
he's feeling dizzy Oh Chinese guy would
never do that
good busy Johnny dude
they're busy hoarding their money and
getting on first before you get out of
an elevator yeah and they're real I'm
getting out like well I'm getting on and
I'm first
I feel like Chinese people are the new
black people whoo I think Jews with the
old black people we were the original
the oeob yeah oh oh and yeah yeah we
were the lowest class we were the worst
we all were the boxers we were all the
and word jobs you know really we
there was a whole basketball thing to
Syracuse Jews that was a basketball team
back that we ran it and then we
lift ourselves up luckily we didn't have
to overcome slavery so we're a little
ahead of you guys but you know in 300
years black people you'll be right where
we are well both together be on
Mexicans really yeah dude what Mexicans
are gonna be pissed
you know they'll be pissed but don't be
they only sleep because they
said they're awful we got on we saw this
sha'ban brand and and and Carlin
yeah you said you we were talking about
like you know gender bias and like
that and you out of the blue it's okay
it's not like I mean I do disagree with
you but like I get it when you're like a
lowest of the low
I understand what you're saying but like
no that's the thing about free speech
you had the right to say that and I'll
defend that to the end but I mean if I
was a Mexican I would stab you but I
mean I
I'm not my Mexican so I can't tell you
how to do your business you can stab me
or Ari Shaffir were you playing soon Ari
I'll be in a Tehran is almost sold out
but I'll be in West Palm and Miami I'll
be in Tempe and Tempe and Phoenix in
both of those in March and then uh then
I'll Cleveland and Columbus and
like that wow it's a lot of same places
I'm going in here probably we are you
with Justin
I'm with CAA okay yeah I'm probably the
same like people running this show yeah
so go to art of the Great Khan for
tickets got a podcast skeptic tank yeah
I gotta come on again sometime yeah I
know we got a great one about hiking
after you got back from Kilimanjaro yeah
it was crazy man it's been a couple
years I have to come on again we got a
long time yeah
I'd love to do that that was one of the
most unique well podcast I've done just
cuz it's different yeah Kevin Nealon has
a hi c'mon I'm gonna go do it's all
about hiker
yeah I think it's a different topic
every time soup's on the topic of hiking
like let's hike while we do this that's
a good idea
ya have to find something else that I'm
doing it yeah we can relax Australia or
something I don't know yeah some
experience like you've just finished cuz
then I could talk to you yeah it's get
your take on it yeah maybe we'll talk
about relapse after you get back from
Australia
I'm scared is a bad coke brother middle
name feel bad cook but I'll tell you
what if you do relapse and and you don't
want to admit that right you do we can
record the pockets and I'll hold it and
to come out and tell everybody you have
my word on that he's an honorable man
you always get it straight from him Ari
Shaffir thanks for coming man no butter
yeah good to see you brother
[Music]
I'll share this piece of thought it's
gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]